an intriguing character from marvel
comics catalog will be getting his very
first solo movie vehicle in 2021
shang chi master of kung fu who is shang
chi and how did he come to be the master
of kung fu
and what is his place within the world
of marvel comics we're here to break
down the details for you
you may be aware that in the early 1970s
everybody was kung fu fighting or at
least they wanted to be
this was largely thanks to bruce lee who
had been exposed to american audiences
via the television series the green
hornet
and with starring roles in films
including game of death
and the posthumously released enter the
dragon which kicked open the door for
future superstars like jackie chan the
tv series kung fu which starred actor
david carradine
is said to have originally been
developed for bruce lee marvel hoped to
adapt the series to cash in on the
martial arts craze but the house of
ideas was
unable to obtain the rights as quickly
as you can
snatch the pebble from my hand
[Applause]
so then marvel publisher stan lee turned
to creators
steve ingleheart and jim starlin to come
up with an original kung fu based
property the character they created
would go on to become a
marvel mainstay in the late 80s long
before marvel came to dominate the box
office
stanley attempted to get a shang chi
movie off the ground starring brandon
lee bruce's son
it never materialized not everyone was
convinced that master of kung fu would
be an instant hit
so marvel introduced the character in a
dead-end book with the clunky title of
special marvel edition which had
up to that point published 14 issues of
reprints of older marvel stories
much like spider-man who first appeared
in amazing fantasy number 15
chang chi debuted in the pages of
special marvel edition number 15
published in december 1973 the public
quickly took notice
it only took two issues for the book's
former title to be dropped
it was renamed hands of shang chi master
of kung fu for the remainder of its run
which lasted until 1983.
shang chi enjoyed a respectable level of
popularity throughout the 70s making
guest appearances in several of marvel's
flagship books and interacting with some
of its most
high-profile characters despite the
success it was
as they say a different time and some
elements of the character's backstory
were more than a little questionable
chief among these problems was shang
chi's lineage
in his very first appearance he was
presented as the son of the evil fu
manchu an overtly racist
super villain who had appeared in pulp
novels and movies throughout the 20th
century the character was among the most
popular of the so-called
yellow peril villains which spawned a
number of devious heartless asian evil
doers such as flash gordon archvillain
ming the merciless and the batman
villain
roz al ghul marvel obtained the rights
from fu manchu's creator british
novelist sex romer and while their
characterization was a touch more
dignified
many asian readers nevertheless found
the character to represent a
demonization of their culture
in his original origin shang chi was
raised by his father to be the ultimate
assassin but quickly came to reject fu
manchu's evil ways
over the years the two would clash
repeatedly in later years the identity
of the hero's father would be ret conned
to actually be the immortal sorcerer
zhang zhu who for decades had simply
been using fu manchu as an alias
but this was largely due to the rights
reverting back to romer's estate rather
than a desire to rehab the character
like many of marvel's heroes shang chi
technically doesn't have any superpowers
he was molded by his father into the
ultimate weapon a master practitioner of
all forms of chinese martial arts
not only does this mean that he's an
absurdly skilled fighter it also means
that he has a level of control over his
body that few characters in the marvel
universe can match
he's able to regulate a number of
supposedly involuntary bodily functions
for example he can reduce the function
of his nerves to the extent that he's
practically impervious to pain
and he can even slow down the rate at
which he bleeds he also has a master's
knowledge of pressure points enabling
him to take down opponents with a single
strike and is known to unleash
a bone-rattling flying kick which packs
an unbelievable amount of force behind
it
like captain america he's said to
represent the peak of human strength
power and agility
he does however boast one skill specific
to only the most skilled of martial
artists one that raises his abilities to
a level slightly beyond those of fellow
non-powered heroes
chang chi has the ability to focus his
chi the spiritual energy or life force
inherent to all living things
in real world martial arts this practice
is used mainly in meditation and as a
way of controlling one's fear and anger
in the marvel universe the ability can
be honed into a weapon
and shang chi uses it to augment his
skills to devastating effect he can
temporarily boost his strength and
endurance beyond even peak human levels
dodge or deflect bullets and control his
body's reaction to poison or drugs
because of these abilities and his utter
mastery of an array of deadly fighting
styles
shang chi is often considered to be the
greatest unarmed combatant in the entire
marvel universe he was deemed by no less
in authority than black panther to be an
even more formidable fighter than the
super-powered iron fist
his mastery over his qi has even
received a technological boost
at times he uses a special pair of
nunchucks designed by tony stark which
can accumulate and disperse shang chi's
spiritual energy
unleashing deadly concussive blasts
shang chi's interactions with other
marvel heroes has been frequent but one
of his wilder team ups was with an
unlikely band of new york-based heroes
it started with an investigation into
the bizarre slaughter of an entire
faction of brooklyn mafia members
daredevil discovered it was the work of
eulek a rock troll
hailing from asgard's underworld who had
come to earth in search of a mystical
horn
daredevil enlisted the aid of shang chi
black widow a cloakless dagger
and the punisher to form the marvel
knights and deal with eulek and his
minions
afterwards the rest of the group became
determined to bring the punisher whose
methods they found to be unsavory to
justice
they were joined in this dangerous
endeavor by moon knight but the revamped
group's efforts were interrupted by
cloak who was in the psychological
clutches of the demon nightmare and was
on a misguided rampage to consume all
evildoers after consuming the punisher
daredevil black widow and moon knight
cloak was halted by dr strange whom
dagger had brought in to assist before
things got truly out of hand by the end
of the series the punisher was still
punishing away chiang chi has
occasionally been called upon to train
other heroes in hand-to-hand combat
including your friendly neighborhood
wall crawler during the revenge of the
spider slayer story arc spider-man
realized that the villain alistair
smythe had found a way to imbue his
spider slayer
robots with a version of his spider
sense he created a device to disrupt the
ability but was forced to set it off
manually
deactivating his own spider sense in the
process this caused some difficulty in
the subsequent spider island event
during which
thousands of heroes villains and
ordinary citizens alike developed spider
powers
on the recommendation of madame webb
spidey went to shang qi for training
he created a completely new martial arts
style intended to complement
spider-man's powers which he called the
way of the spider
spider-man became an even more dangerous
fighter than he already was using his
newfound martial arts prowess to take
down opponents as powerful and skilled
as spider-woman and even
shang chi himself shang chi has at times
been imparted with superhuman abilities
during the aforementioned spider island
event he was one of the many temporarily
granted the same powers of spider-man
a scary notion if ever there was one he
used these powers to help dispatch the
threat of these spider-powered
supervillains running roughshod over new
york city
in another incident chang chi was
dispatched with other avengers to the
fictional island of
madrapor to deal with an ancient dragon
which had been awakened from its slumber
underneath the island using pym
particles
shang chi enlarged himself to match the
dragon's godzilla-like stature and
promptly defeated it in combat
in a more recent incident sheng chi
volunteered to investigate the city of
kobe japan after it was struck with the
evolution speeding origin bomb by the
god-like entity known as
ex-nelio while others had been absorbed
by the genesis matter which was a
byproduct of the bombing
shangshi was able to commune with it and
in the process gained the ability to
produce an unknown number of duplicates
of himself
each one with the original's memories
and abilities it's unknown whether he
still
possesses this power back in 2006 when
marvel first announced its intentions to
start marvel studios and produce a slate
of films featuring some of its lesser
known characters virtually no one was
thinking that the endeavor would result
in the single highest grossing film
franchise of all time
avengers
assemble the rights to marvel's most
famous properties namely spider-man and
the x-men were held by sony and fox
respectively both of which had created
successful film franchises
marvel seemed to be coming late to the
party with a stable of characters that
included in the order they were
announced captain america the avengers
nick fury black panther
ant-man cloak and dagger doctor strange
hawkeye power pack and shang chi
marvel studios would of course go on to
elevate many of these properties to
household name status
although some took considerably longer
to develop than others
ant-man took a full nine years to reach
the big screen and the pre-teen power
pack have yet to get its time in the
spotlight
but finally well over a decade after the
fact shang chi
stands poised to join the mcu thanks in
part to another solo vehicle which
became one of marvel's biggest success
stories and one of the biggest films of
2018.
black panther astonished audiences
crafted mainly by african american
filmmakers and featuring a hero who is
the king of the technologically advanced
african nation of wakanda
this never gets old the film proved that
big budget blockbusters created from a
specific cultural viewpoint can resonate
strongly with general audiences and it
even outgrossed the juggernaut that was
avengers infinity war at the domestic
box office
taking a cue from this success marvel
appears to have gone all
in on diversity and it's likely the
studios hope that shang chi
and the legend of the ten rings can
strike a similar chord in pop culture
at large to this end the production has
been loaded up with talented people of
asian descent on both sides of the
camera
japanese irish american destin daniel
cretan will direct from a screenplay by
chinese american scribe
dave callahan who is contributing to
warner brothers upcoming wonder woman
1984 as well as sony pictures
animation's as yet
untitled sequel to spider-man into the
spider-verse chinese canadian actor
simul liu has landed the title role and
the suddenly ubiquitous rapper turned
actor aquafina will appear
among the supporting cast legendary
chinese actor tony lion will co-star as
the mandarin
an iconic villain who many fans feel was
previously given extremely short
shrift the title of shangchi's solo
vehicle quickly got the attention of
marvel fans alluding as it does to a
mysterious terrorist organization that
has lurked in the shadows of the mcu
since its inception the ten rings are
the group responsible for tony stark's
kidnapping in iron man
they've been alluded to in both of that
film sequels as well as ant-man they're
led by none other than the real mandarin
who famously wears a ring on every
finger in the comics
this is not the phony trevor slattery or
his handler aldrich killian both of whom
have falsely laid claim to the mandarin
name
where's the mandarin where is he whoa
whoa whoa he's here he's here
but he's not here he's here but he's not
here in shanghai and the legend of the
ten rings
this group will finally step out of the
shadows and truly make their presence
felt the ten rings are dedicated to
nothing less than the destabilization of
the entire planet
sowing the kind of chaos which will lead
to the collapse of world governments and
create a power vacuum they've butted
heads with iron man black widow and nick
fury but they'll soon face the master of
kung fu
who never met a challenge that he
couldn't kick the absolute crap
out of check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the mcu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one